[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui on se demande comment faire
pour mieux associer les salariés à la
performance de leur entreprise les
syndicales patronats en discutent depuis
trois mois la demande du gouvernement
qui veut que le partage de la valeur
soit un des grands chantiers de cette
année 2023 face à un pouvoir d'achat
rogné par l'inflation l'exécutif mise
notamment sur le dividende salarié on en
parlera avec celui qui l'a théorisé
Thibault langsad ancien numéro 2 du
Medef depuis les patrons jouent-ils
suffisamment le jeu de la redistribution
des profits on pose la question à
Laurent Berger le secrétaire général de
la CVT qui sera notre invité mais
d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
ces dispositifs de partage de la valeur
en moins d'une minute c'est parti quels
sont les outils de partage de la valeur
qui existe déjà il y a d'abord la
participation
obligatoire dans les entreprises de plus
de 50 salariés il s'agit d'une prime
basée sur le bénéfice dégagé et versez à
tous les collaborateurs
en 2021 39% des salariés en ont
bénéficié pour un montant moyen de 1500
euros ensuite l'intéressement c'est une
prime annuelle facultative elle est
conditionnée à la performance de
l'entreprise en 2021 34% l'ont reçu pour
un montant moyen de 1909 euros ou encore
la prime de partage de la valeur qui
permet de verser jusqu'à 6000 euros de
bonus par an entre outre et septembre
2022 710 euros ont été versés à 2,5
millions de salariés combien de salariés
sont concernés dans le privé un peu plus
d'un salarié sur deux axé à un
dispositif de partage de la valeur dans
le détail ils sont 88% dans les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés et
moins de 20% dans celle de moins de 50
salariés et le gouvernement il veut
aller plus loin oui il a prévu
l'instauration d'un dividende salarié
l'objectif permettre un meilleur partage
des bénéfices en faveur des salariés
[Musique]
faut-il instaurer un dividende pour les
employeurs un titre que pour les
actionnaires oui il va nous dire
Thibault donc ça de bonjour bonjour
président de Luminess et président de
l'URSSAF c'est comme ça quand vous
appelle le théoricien donc du ce
dividende salarié Emmanuel Macron
l'avait on a fait une promesse de
campagne on s'en souvient le
gouvernement là dans ces cartons donc ça
veut dire que tout entreprises je résume
un petit peu qui versera qui verserait
des dividendes devra aussi en même temps
verser ce dividende salarié tout ça
inscrit dans la loi c'est un peu résumé
mais c'est ça l'idée c'est un peu ça
mais on va partir d'un dispositif qui
est déjà existant qui est la
participation autrement
c'est ce qui est important c'est de dire
que sous la bannière dividende et je
vais y revenir pourquoi j'ai appelé ça
le dividende salarié on part d'un
dispositif existant qui date des années
77 des ordonnances de 67 voulues par le
général de Gaulle qui est de faire en
sorte qu'il y a un meilleur partage de
la valeur et donc il faut
c'était déjà contrasté je pense que plus
de 50 ans après il faut revoir ce
dispositif parce que le partage de la
valeur est un acte de réconciliation que
nous devons avoir avec les salariés les
actionnaires je pense qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est très simple c'est que
regarder on est probablement le seul
pays au monde en tout cas en Europe où
chaque fois qu'on verse des dividendes
et qu'on les dividendes sont importants
on crie oh là là c'est disproportionné
c'est trop important voire même c'est
une spoliation qui est fait sur le dos
de l'entreprise du salarié il y a pas un
pays où globalement ça se passe mal
quand on verse des dividendes qui est
quand même signe de vitalité de notre
économie ce dividende salarié plutôt que
de parler en tout cas de dividendes
salariés pourquoi est-ce que on pourrait
pas juste dire la participation et ben
on double sur mon temps on a une formule
de calcul plus intéressante plus
avantageuse pour pour le salarié et en
étant à tous les salariés notamment aux
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés pour
aujourd'hui c'est facultatif voilà ce
que j'ai envie de dire c'est
arrêtons-nous une minute sur le
dividende salarié et j'invite tous les
spectateurs à regarder dans le code du
travail alors qui est un peu épais le
chapitre 3 du Code du travail et on
découvre dans le chapitre 3 du Code du
travail que les instruments
d'intéressement et de participation se
nomme dividende travail et quand j'ai
essayé de théoriser ce dividende salarié
ce meilleur partage de la valeur
partirou il y avait la prime dite Macron
qui est devenu prime partage de la
valeur un troisième dispositif qui s'est
on va dire avancer et bien je me suis
dit finalement il faut renommer ça du
dividende cela et le dividende salarié
c'est chaque entreprise qui verse des
dividendes doit verser de la
participation c'est ça le thème mais
aujourd'hui toute boîte qui fait des
bénéfices de plus 50 salariés doit
verser une participation alors oui mais
vous avez des entreprises qui versent
pas de participation parce qu'elles sont
organisées de telle façon
contenu de la formule de participation
qui ne verse pas de participation et
donc il faut regarder un contournement
il y a une forte de contournement
d'optimisation et puis vous l'avez dit
justement vous avez 150000 entreprises
on va dire de PME vous avez des moyennes
PME des grosses PME ça fait un peu près
10 millions de salariés et sur ces 10
millions de salariés vous avez que 2
millions 3 qui sont couverts par un
dispositif d'intéressement et de
participation donc 50% des salariés du
privé exactement
ce qui revient à peu près à ça ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut probablement rendre
ce dispositif accessible à l'ensemble
des entreprises à l'exception des moins
de 11 où là la prime partage de la
valeur peut fonctionner parce que il
faut la simplicité mais oui dans les PME
dans les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire il faut que l'on puisse
mettre en place de la participation ce
dividende salarié il pourrait
représenter combien de mois de salaire
je sais pas si on peut leur poser la
question comme ça alors aujourd'hui si
on regarde les masses
intéressement plus participation ça
représente à peu près 20 milliards
on va dire
redistribuer aux salariés si on regarde
la participation c'est globalement 11
milliards
et par montant unitaire par salarié mais
ce qui est pas forcément dire grand
chose parce que là on fait une division
c'est un montant qui va à peu près de
2000 à 3000 euros selon la taille de
l'entreprise alors évidemment des petits
entreprises qui vont donner 500 mais ça
peut représenter globalement c'est ça
l'idée en renforçant le mécanisme de la
participation un mois à 13e ou 14e mois
parce que ce que je propose dans le
dividende salarié c'est plusieurs choses
c'est un c'est de doubler le montant la
participation pour les grandes
entreprises le rendre on va dire
systématique dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 et puis de mettre en place
une formule de participation pour les
PME qui soit plus audible et plus
accessible la participation c'est pas
déjà une forme de dividende du travail
puisque on sait qu'elle est assise sur
le bénéfice de l'entreprise ils avaient
raison c'est au plus près du dividende
donc c'est déjà une cote part du
dividende donc voilà mais je le
réexplique dans la théorie du dividende
salarié d'ailleurs voilà ces contrasté
le patronat aura sa vision les syndicats
par la visio en parler donc je le
réhabilite d'une certaine façon mais oui
vous avez raison la formule de
participation si je la donne là je pense
que tout le monde va se coucher
a juste titre il faut la simplifier mais
elle est déjà une quote part du
dividende
cet ancien numéro 2 du Medef Thibault
langsad le patronat n'est pas fan et
vous le savez de votre dividende salarié
pour le patronat ça augmente le coût du
travail et sa nuit à la compétitivité
ce dividende salarié j'ai envie de dire
oui et non ça augmente
ce sont des dispositifs qui sont on va
dire souvent dénuées de fiscalité de
quoi c'est ce qu'on appelle le
forcercial pour les grandes entreprises
il est inexistant pour les entreprises
de moins de 250 salariés sur
l'intéressement et inexistant sur la
participation pour les moins de 50
salariés donc ce sont des dispositifs
qui peuvent être gagnants gagnants mais
le vrai sujet c'est la réconciliation un
meilleur partage de la valeur et ça
c'est une inspiration que nous voulons
tous et donc parce qu'il y a un problème
de partage de la valeur en France oui un
sujet sur le partage de la valeur les
primes la participation l'intéressement
l'épargne salariale mais au global il y
a un problème de partage je pense que on
a besoin davantage de sens et de être
mieux associés à la performance de
l'onde ça veut dire qu'on prend à qui on
prend l'investissement on prend aux
dividendes aux actionnaires pas qu'il
faut il faille le raisonner comme ça je
pense que la nécessité c'est d'avoir des
investissements qui permettent le gâteau
pas infini non mais il faut aussi avoir
des instruments qui permettent d'avoir
une répartition légèrement plus
équitable quand l'entreprise sur
performes c'est le sujet que nous avons
aujourd'hui je dis pas que quand une
entreprise est en difficulté elle peut
pas verser de dividendes elle va pas
d'intéressement de participation mais
quand vous avez des résultats
exceptionnels ce qui est quand même le
cas de nos entreprises et une fois de
plus c'est à la gloire de notre
industrie c'est à la gloire de notre
économie tant mieux ça nous permet
d'avoir un chômage en diminution de
verser une contribution on va dire
fiscale plus importante en 2022 qui
permettra à l'état de mieux équilibrer
son budget donc on a une contribution
mais quand on a des résultats importants
d'avoir un meilleur partage de la valeur
53 après revoir les dispositifs
intéressants de participation je pense
que ça vaut le coup allez merci beaucoup
Thibault lanxa donc président de
lumineux c'est président de l'URSSAF
merci merci alors quels sont les autres
solutions pour mieux partager la valeur
au sein de l'entreprise on en parle tout
de suite avec le patron de la CFDT
[Musique]
comment mieux associer les salariés au
succès de leur entreprise on en parle
avec vous Laurent Berger bonjour bonjour
secrétaire général de la CFDT ce partage
de la valeur c'est pas un sujet qui est
nouveau ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle
des décennies diront certains et je me
rappelle Nicolas Sarkozy en son temps
qui parlait de la règle des trois tirs à
propos de la répartition des bénéfices
entières pour les actionnaires un tiers
pour les investissements et un tiers
pour les salariés ça n'a jamais vu le
jour vous le regrettez pas à l'époque à
la tête de la CFDT c'est une bonne
répartition vous pourriez signer ça
aujourd'hui bah le principe d'un tiers
un tiers 1/3 peut paraître un peu ne pas
tenir compte de la diversité des
entreprises mais en tout cas ce principe
que dans le partage de la valeur créée
il y en a un tiers pour les actionnaires
un tiers pour de l'investissement et un
tiers qui aille au travailleur pour le
pour parce qu'ils ont participé à la
création de valeur effectivement le
principe est intéressant après est-ce
qu'il faut le faire avec autant de de de
précision je suis pas sûr on peut aussi
estimer que la négociation entreprise
permettrait de d'affiner selon la
situation de chaque entreprise ce qui
est sûr aujourd'hui c'est que on le voit
dans le partage de la valeur ajoutée
depuis des années la part des salaires à
peu près stable oui mais il y a eu un
phénomène d'optimisation fiscale
grandissant qui fait que il y a une part
grandissante de la richesse créée dans
certains nombre de grandes entreprises
qui échappent d'une part à la richesse
nationale d'une certaine manière par la
fiscalité mais qui échappe à la
redistribution de la valeur donc on a
une distorsion qui sont qui s'est opérée
de salaire puisque la part des salaires
dans la valeur ajoutée depuis la fin des
années montre vous l'avez dit que tout
ça est stable c'est il y a un sujet
salaire y compris la négociation qu'on
est en train de mener nous on se dit on
peut pas mettre de côté le sujet salaire
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a au-delà de ça
le sujet participation intéressement
dispositif de de répartition de la
valeur créée envers les salariés qui est
aujourd'hui très insuffisante après il y
a la question sur la question du salaire
évidemment il y a l'inflation et donc
à l'inflation ce sujet la plus partage
de la valeur comme on augmente pas les
salaires revient sur la table et déjà
sur la question des augmentations de
salaire le compte n'y est pas
aujourd'hui on a qu'on a 6% d'inflation
sur 2022 3,7% de salaire nous a dit le
ministère du Travail ça rattrapera pas
l'inflation il faut bien d'autres
mécanismes à côté le compte n'est pas ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que d'abord les
salaires doivent suivre les mécanismes
d'inflation c'est-à-dire que il doit
avoir des négociations salariales dans
les entreprises dans les branches
professionnelles qui permettent de
compenser l'inflation
des salaires on veut pas l'indexer nous
on veut des négociations vous savez
aujourd'hui il y a à chaque
revalorisation du SMIC on est à peu près
à 130 branches qui sont en dessous qui
démarre avec des minimas en dessous du
SMIC là il faut des mécanismes beaucoup
plus dynamiques dans les branches en
termes de négociation et donc il faut
des incitations en direction des
branches professionnelles du côté
patronal pour négocier donc il y a un
sujet salaire qui est posé à travers ses
branches et à travers les négociations
annuelles obligatoires
aujourd'hui si on fait le bilan sur 2022
il y a des endroits où ça s'est passé
avec des négociations salariales qui ont
été à la hauteur des endroits où on a
des stations salariales qui ne
compensent pas l'inflation et il y a eu
parfois des augmentations à travers la
prime de la prime Paypal ou donc qui
compensaient plus ou moins il y a des
endroits où ça ne compense pas du tout
il y a des secteurs professionnels où il
y a une perte de pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce qu'on fait énorme là je crois
qu'il faut vraiment inciter à une
revalorisation des des grilles
salariales dans les branches
professionnelles vous savez quand vous
avez trois ou quatre échelons qui sont
en dessous le SMIC avant même de avant
même de discuter dans les entreprises du
salaire ça veut dire que vous restez au
SMIC pendant des mois et des mois des
années des années sans compenser de
reconnaître d'abord votre compétence
parce classification et sans compenser
les pertes de pouvoir d'achat donc il y
a vraiment une logique de politique
salariale qu'il faut distinguer de de
la discussion qu'on a aujourd'hui sur le
partage de la valeur ajoutée mais il
faut le distinguer mais la question
salariale doit être intégrée quand même
dans les discussions qu'on a avec le
patrona wake c'est un peu compliqué
comme les comme moi le travail le
salaire c'est ce que vous vous recevez
en fonction de la tâche que vous
effectuez c'est ce qu'on vous paye pour
faire ce travail le partage de la valeur
c'est ce qui vous revient quand vous
êtes un salarié parce que vous avez créé
de la valeur ça passe donc pas seulement
par le salaire les hausses de salaire
mais il y a aussi les prix
la participation m'intéressement le
numéro 2 du Medef me disait Patrick
Martin quand on met tout sa bout à bout
ça compense l'inflation tous ces
mécanismes c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai le le en moyenne faudrait
regarder ça se discute mais c'est pas
les moyens qui comptent vous voyez bien
que les salariés de ce pays ils en ont
un peu assez qu'on les considère en
moyenne c'est-à-dire puisque il y a eu
des augmentations qui dans certains
secteurs c'est vrai parce qu'il y a de
la valeur créée ou parce que il y a
beaucoup de participation
d'intéressement
masque finalement la réalité de salariés
plus modeste ça marche pas vous savez
les dispositifs de participation
intéressement ça existe pour à peu près
en moyenne 55% des des salariés mais 83%
des salariés des grandes entreprises en
bénéficient et 17% les autres des
salariés de moins de 10 donc vous voyez
c'est pour arrêter de fonctionner en
moyenne aujourd'hui dans tout un tas
d'entreprises il y a pas de mécanisme
distribution de la valeur de la valeur
créée c'est pour ça que nous dans la
négociation réclame la participation des
dispositifs de participation ou
d'intéressement obligatoire de
l'entreprise et un calcul simplifié
aujourd'hui cette obligatoire la
participation au-delà de 50 salariés
vous plaidez-vous pour abaisser ce seuil
pour élargir la participation
de participation pour toutes les
entreprises obligatoires et que ce soit
avec un mécanisme de calcul qui soit
très simple que dit patronat le patronat
est opposé à ça la négociation est
aujourd'hui dans une forme d'impasse en
tout cas dans une grosse difficulté le
patronat aujourd'hui les seules
propositions qu'il fait c'est
non obligations de mécanisme de
participation et
allègement fiscaux
qui existent déjà renforcement le
renforcement du forfait social
renforcement des allègements fiscaux
pour distribuer de de
enfin le fruit de la valeur créée aux
salariés franchement c'est pas sérieux
donc on est dans une négociation qui est
aujourd'hui est en panne du certaine
manière on a jusqu'au 31 janvier on a
une dernière séance le 31 janvier moi je
le dis au patronat de toute façon c'est
très sérieux je leur dis en direct aussi
si vous ne trouvez pas un point d'accord
si on n'arrive pas à trouver un point
d'accord et vous ne faites pas un effort
de toute façon on plaidera après auprès
du gouvernement pour qu'un dispositif
obligatoire existe mais mais prenez
conscience que c'est beaucoup moins
intelligent que sur l'été capable de
trouver un point d'accord ce que propose
le gouvernement c'est notamment cette
prime Macron versée en 2021 à 4 millions
de salariés pour un montant moyen de 500
euros montant qui a été rehaussé en 2022
à 710 euros est-ce que c'est bien on se
dit qu'on est loin du plafond de 6000
euros potentiel et puis c'est au bon
vouloir de l'employeur donc c'est
d'abord dire lorsque des salariés 4
millions de salariés et touchent 500
euros de plus à travers une prime dire
que c'est pas bien
c'est de ne pas le faire quand on a un
syndicaliste parce que j'imagine que
pour un certain nombre de salariés ça a
été bénéfique mais un c'est pas
obligatoire vous l'avez dit deux ça sert
à rien de fixer un plafond astronomique
pour finalement ne pas avoir ne pas ne
pas y arriver et 3 nous on pense que
c'est dispositifs de prime ça doit être
en cas de non de non de non-accord de
non accorde faire la participation c'est
à dire que ça peut pas être le
dispositif pérenne vous voyez ce que je
veux dire il faut un dispositif qui soit
obligatoire là c'est au bon vouloir donc
il y a eu des périodes spécifiques avec
le covid la période poscovide
l'inflation etc on a bien vu que ça a pu
marcher pour 4 millions c'est pas neutre
mais ça ne marchera pas les années à
venir si on remplaça obligatoire ne tant
que fille est parti naissent le patron
de la CGT dit et c'est vrai une prime
c'est ponctuel alors que le salaire
c'est tous les mois mais en même temps
de manière exceptionnelle une prime ça
peut aider à booster le pouvoir d'achat
oui vous savez c'est toujours faut pas
être déconnecté de la réalité quand vous
versez
et il faut il peut y avoir dispositif de
prix mais nous ce qu'on préconise avant
tout c'est des revalorisations
salariales et des dispositifs de
répartition de la richesse créée
d'entreprise qui soit pérenne donc pour
tous c'est participation pour tous c'est
clair bon d'ailleurs le gouvernement va
mettre en place le dividende salarié en
gros dès que l'entreprise verse des
dividendes aux actionnaires elle doit
récompenser aussi ses salariés ça vous
plaît c'est saugrenu vous n'êtes pas
contre parce que c'est une façon de
contraindre quelque part les patrons à
redistribuer la valeur peu importe ce
soit le bon terme ou pas ça existe enfin
on peut le faire en élargissant les
dispositifs de participation ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut se dire c'est il se
passe quoi c'est qu'est-ce qu'on entend
par dividende verset vous voyez dans
tout un tas d'entreprises ça sera pas la
dividende notamment les entreprises
assez petites ce sera pas la dividende
versée à des actionnaires dont on sait
pas où en fonction du cours de la bourse
donc il faudra trouver une méthode de de
calcul qui soit autre nous on est plutôt
en fonction de des bénéfices créés par
entreprise qu'il y a une part qui
mécaniquement automatiquement reverse ça
s'appelle la participation ouais bien
sûr voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai essayé
de l'expliquer différemment mais ça
s'appelle la partie situation mais oui
mais c'est ça qu'il faut faire il faut
un dispositif simplifié dans le calcul
déjà on est là il faut l'élargir le
rendre obligatoire aux entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés bien sûr aux
entreprises de moins de 50 et minimum
avec un système minimum de participation
avec non je crois avec une famille sur
une base 100 il y a 100 de valeur créée
il faut qu'on calcule qu'il y a tant qui
reviennent aux salariés parce qu'ils ont
participé à la création de cette formule
de calcul qui est très complexe pour la
simplifier objectivement faut la
simplifier parce que généreuse
pour les salariés oui je vous remercie
de le proposer mais non mais c'est
surtout faut la simplifier parce que
l'idée c'est pas de complexifier ce que
disent ce que disent ce que vivent des
chefs d'entreprise dans les petites
entreprises mais ici c'est simple c'est
un pourcentage et que c'est et que c'est
facile à calculer il y a aucune raison
de pas le généraliser et aussi un autre
mécanisme qui plaît au gouvernement
c'est la super participation en gros
elle traverse salarié des entreprises
qui réalisent des super dividendes en
gros des dividendes qui sont supérieurs
de 20% la moyenne des 5 dernières années
pardon c'était pour être précis là aussi
vous êtes ouvert quel que soit le nom
l'appellation en fait
nous on est ouvert à ça et il faut il
faut effectivement que quand il y a des
déversements beaucoup de versements de
dividendes ça il y a aussi une part qui
a eu salarié mais on aurait tort dans le
débat actuel de polariser seulement sur
les grandes entreprises dont on connaît
les grands noms et dans on se dirait
c'est celle là celle-là parce que bah on
a tort les stigmatiser en tout cas on a
tort de croire que de faire croire qu'on
aura réglé le problème de partage de la
valeur ajoutée quand on aura traité le
sujet dans ces entreprises là c'est ce
que dit le patron de la CGT en disant
regardez 80 milliards d'euros de
dividendes vers fonctionnaires sur le
CAC 40 mais sur les dividendes versés
aux actionnaires il y a deux il y a deux
actions qu'il faut mener c'est il faut
de l'inversement salariés à proportion
c'est une évidence et puis il faut
regarder aussi ça veut dire de
participation qui soit et les boutiques
d'ailleurs souvent dans les grands
groupes super participation etc oui bien
sûr pour ça c'est pour ça vous savez il
faut pas se masquer derrière quelques
quelques réalités qui existent et sur
lesquelles il faut traiter les choses
pour qu'il y a un meilleur partage de la
valeur ajoutée dans les grandes
entreprises mais en se disant quand on
aura réglé ça on aura réglé le problème
de travailleurs dans tout dans toutes
les entreprises c'est pas vrai le
problème il est d'abord pour les
entreprises des petites les petites
entreprises l'entreprise de taille
intermédiaires les PME etc où il faut
trouver un mécanisme facile à mettre en
oeuvre qui permettent la le partage la
valeur ajoutée dans les grandes
entreprises si vous voulez sur les faits
bon vivre pardon pour les salariés dans
les grandes entreprises ils ont la
participation les salariés ils ont
l'intéressement ils ont il y a beaucoup
de choses oui mais bien sûr parce que
parce qu'il y a eu de l'action syndicale
aussi bien sûr parce qu'il y a de la
richesse créée ça veut pas dire que il
faut pas qu'on réfléchisse quand même à
des dividendes qui sont qui sont chaque
année en tout cas depuis deux ans
toujours plus important l'idée pour la
CFDT c'est pas simplement de de partage
de la valeur mais sur les le le le
dividendes notamment ce que rapporte le
capital je crois qu'il y aura besoin
aussi de d'aller vers une politique
fiscale qui soit qui soit plus juste et
qu'on avait fait l'impôt sur les
sociétés
la France qui revient de loin oui oui
mais il y a la CFDT elle a jamais été
pour le contre-rétaurer des marches aux
entreprises vous savez le pacte de
responsabilité le cice etc ça peut avoir
du sens mais quand
les super dividendes ou il y a outrance
d'une certaine manière dans le versement
des dividendes parfois avec des
mécanismes d'optimisation fiscale etc il
est pas anormal de se reposer la
question de comment il peut ça peut
contribuer aussi à la richesse nationale
s'il y a trop de dividendes c'est au
détriment des des salariés des salaires
on va pas dans toutes les entreprises ça
peut être dans certaines entreprises ça
peut être au détriment des salariés et
de leur salaire de leur de leur
participation y compris parce qu'elle
n'existe pas mais dans d'autres dans
d'autres cas ça peut être au détriment
de la valeur de la de la richesse
nationale quand on parle de
l'enrichissement des actionnaires on dit
souvent il vient des dividendes mais si
on regarde bien les choses ça vient
plutôt ça vient des dividendes bien sûr
mais surtout de la valorisation des
marchés boursiers et si les bourses sont
beaucoup montés regardent le poids
boursier du CAC40 dans le PIB c'était
50% en 98 on est à 100% aujourd'hui
c'est de la faute entre guillemets
notamment des banques centrales des
politiques de taux d'intérêt très très
faible donc l'enrichissement des
actionnaires est venu pour partie
vivante surtout de la hausse de la
valeur de leurs actifs liés aux
politiques monétaires extrêmement
similiantes stimulante pendant des
années et des années donc on est sorti
d'ailleurs là aujourd'hui mais c'est
pour ça que il faut pas que c'est plus
complexe que vous savez il y a deux
choses il faut pas deux risques qu'il
faut vers lequel il faut pas aller le
premier qui serait dire il y a rien à
bouger là-dessus et la répartition de la
valeur créée est non elle est pas juste
aujourd'hui donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
souhaité s'engager dans cette dans cette
négociation et qu'on espère que si elle
n'aboutit pas
mais le gouvernement commence à
responsabilité puis à l'autre risque
d'avoir lequel il faut pas tomber qu'il
serait de trouver anormal que quelqu'un
qui investit n'est pas un juste retour
de son investissement et sa prise de
risque mais il y a une distorsion
aujourd'hui une profonde distension qui
s'est créée notamment dans certains
secteurs professionnels mais surtout
dans certaines entreprises et donc le
rétablissement de la répartition entre
le capital et le travail il est
absolument nécessaire pour que ce soit
plus juste et pourquoi ne pas plaider à
Laurent Berger pour une un développement
une massification de l'actionna salarié
comme ça on aligne un peu les intérêts
entre les actionnaires et les salariés
vous savez quand vous êtes salarié vous
vous
[Musique]
des partenaires sociaux pour l'instant
non la négociation n'est pas terminée
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de on
n'est pas sur la bonne voie pour un
accord parce que donc ça risque de finir
avec le dividende salarié oui mais là
encore
le moment venu je dirais au gouvernement
il faudra faire quelque chose
d'intelligent qui soit qui soit quand
même dans praticable pour que le but
finalement c'est que la richesse soit
mieux répartie d'entreprise notamment
dans les pays que ce soit pas juste
cosmétiques notamment dans les petits
évidemment notamment dans les petites et
les moyens d'entreprises je vous
remercie pour cet entretien de Robert à
vous secrétaire général de la CVT merci
beaucoup voilà c'est la fin de pourvu
que ça dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondables sur Public Sénat
émission à voir ou revoir sur Public
Sénat qui a du replay bien sûr sur
publicena.fr rendez-vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]